hey what's up guys my name is the Cherno
and welcome to the first episode of a
brand new series in his series we'll be
taking a look at creating flappy bird a
popular mobile game that should be
simpler not to make our end result look
something like what you're seeing right
now let's talk a bit about the
technology behind the game we'll be
making firstly this won't be a mobile
game we'll be making a desktop version
of flappy bird which will be
cross-platform we'll be using Java and
object-oriented programming language
that supports really fast development at
least compared to something like C++
inside Java will be using OpenGL OpenGL
is a graphic specification which is
already integrated into your graphics
card
I recommend updating your graphics
drivers to ensure you've got a modern
version of OpenGL OpenGL is written in C
so we need a way to access that inside
Java out of the many available libraries
out there will be using LW jgl which
sounds the lightweight Java game library
in addition to letting us call OpenGL
from inside Java l dubba jgl provides a
nice interface for input devices even
though we're using lwg l don't worry l w
GL simply allows us to call the opengl
code which is written in c from inside
java making it no different than if we
use C to write the application since the
graphics part of it effectively is
written in C finally we'll be using
OpenGL 3.3 as a minimum version the
current stable release of OpenGL as of
right now is 4.4 however OpenGL 4 is
generally not supported in graphics
cards released earlier than 2010 for
example the NVIDIA GeForce 300 series
only supports OpenGL 3.3 and lower
because of this there's really no point
in us exclusively using OpenGL 4 to make
this game since we're essentially
limiting our games run only on graphics
cards released within the last four
years OpenGL 3.3 sets us back to around
2006 since most graphics cards in that
era now have drivers which allow them to
run
OpenGL 3.3 sure we miss out a few need
features from OpenGL 4 but there are
ways to work around that the way we're
going to write the code is modern
practice however basically the way you
would make this kind of game right now
in 2014 will get more into that as the
series goes on in this first episode
we'll be covering everything you need to
do to set up the environment in which
we'll make this game there are three
main ingredients
Java Eclipse and LW JGL check out the
description below for a link to download
java you want the latest version of the
JDK the Java development kit
if you think you might already have Java
installed you can check by opening a
command prompt on windows by pressing
Windows key R and typing in CMD and
hitting Enter
if you're on Mac or Linux simply open
the terminal once that opens type in
Java - version and hit enter if your
version is lower than 1.8 I'd recommend
following along and downloading the
latest version
make sure you accept the agreement and
download the appropriate version for
your platform once downloaded follow the
prompts and install it next we have
eclipse once again check the description
for a link I'll be using Eclipse 4.4
codename Luna for this series Eclipse
doesn't have an installer simply unzip
and place the main folder in a directory
of your choice I'll be placing it in a
dedicated folder for this series once
it's extracted that's it eclipse is
ready to use
lastly we'll need LW JGL whose link is
also in the description click on the
latest version and go ahead and download
it as you can see I'll be using two
point nine point one for this series
once download is simply extracted into a
directory I'll be placing it in our
flappy bird folder together with eclipse
you'll also want to make one final
folder here called workspace this will
contain our Eclipse workspace for this
project basically it'll contain our
actual code and your resources and the
resulting binaries now let's walk
through setting up eclipse firstly open
it if this is your first time opening
Eclipse you'll be asked to select the
workspace go ahead and point into the
workspace folder we just made and check
use this as the default once eclipse
opens let's make a few changes to how it
works
these changes aren't necessary simply me
setting up my workspace the way I like
it let's open the navigator by hitting
window show view and navigator I prefer
this over the package Explorer because
it more or less shows our hierarchy of
folders next we'll hit window then
preferences under Java and code style
we'll click organize imports here we'll
change the number of static imports
needed to 1 we'll see this in action
later next we'll click on format up and
edit this refers to how eclipse formats
our code we'll have to give this profile
a new name so I usually just append
modified under control statements I'm
going to change the way simple if and
else statements are formatted by
essentially keeping them on the same
line on the line wrapping I'll make sure
that we have enough line width to work
with without eclipse wrapping it finally
under comments I'll prevent eclipse
formatting block comments and increase
the line width here as well that's it
we're done now let's go ahead and make
our flappy bird project click file new
and Java project I'm going to call this
project flappy make sure you're using a
Java SAE execution environment the
latest version you've got as you can see
I'll be using 1.8 for this series once
created we need to link LW jgl to our
project right click on the project and
click properties then head over to the
Java build path under the libraries tab
I'll click on add external jars and then
navigate to a lwl folder the only jar
we'll need to add is either the LW a gel
jar or the LW JGL - DVR jar this is a
simple project so it won't be needing
the extra debugging features so I'll add
the former LW a gel uses some C code to
interact with OpenGL so we'll have two
point Java to the location of that code
we can do that by expanding LW jgl
clicking on native library location then
edit and finally pasting in the location
path this is under the native folder
we're using Windows but you should
choose the platform you're developing on
let's grab that path and paste it in
optionally you could have clicked on
external folder and found it that's it
you're done we're now ready to make
flappy bird if something didn't make
sense in this episode or something went
wrong for you please visit my forums and
make a post under the flappy bird
session someone will definitely help you
out there don't forget to like the video
if you enjoyed it and I'll see you guys
next time with episode 2 where we'll
make the display goodbye